bet you've never seen a rhino beetle in
this classy of a scene that's darn a
romantic if I could be so bold wait no I
didn't mean it
stop cut to a new scene please better
thank you actually though Rhino beetles
look so spectacular because of sex lots
of species of Rhino beetles are crawling
around out there with all manner of
different head shapes but it's only the
male's that have those strange faces
which they use to fight their rivals
depending on the shape of the weapons
some species will grab their foes while
others will more scoop it the idea isn't
to inflict damage but to boot their
rival off the branch females don't have
weird faces because they don't need them
this kind of physical contrast between
the sexes is known as sexual dimorphism
think about male sheep I have to
headbutt the bejesus out of each other
for the right to mate females they're
like hey whatever and so the male Rhino
beetle fights for the ladies really
again I'm calling HR